bienvenidos a esta segunda parte de la
exposición acerca de la fórmula
cuadrática y repasemos muy rápido y
brevemente lo que discutíamos la fórmula
cuadrática nos sirve para encontrar las
raíces o los ceros de un polinomio
cuadrática de un polinomio de grado 2
entonces decíamos que si teníamos un
polinomio de grado 2 en su forma más
general era algo de la forma a donde a
es una constante por x al cuadrado más b
por equis
+ c que sería el término independiente y
lo que queremos hacer es igualar esto a
0 y lo que nos dice la fórmula
cuadrática es que bueno si tienes esto y
que resolver esta ecuación entonces vas
a tener dos soluciones vas a tener que x
va a ser igual a menos b - b más menos
la raíz cuadrada
de de cuadrada de cuadrada menos cuatro
veces a por c menos cuatro veces
por c
todo eso dentro de la raíz cuadrada y a
todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre dos
veces dos veces
así que ahora voy a hacer más ejemplos
para tratar de clarificar cómo se usa
esto bien comencemos con el polinomio
menos 9 x al cuadrado menos 9 x + 6
y voy a querer que este polinomio sea
igual a 0 para que valores de x esto es
igual a 0
cuáles son las raíces de este polinomio
de aquí y bueno lo que me dice la
ecuación cuadrática es simplemente van a
ser estas las raíces pero bien quién
está en este caso en este ejemplo a
siempre es el coeficiente de x al
cuadrado el coeficiente de x al cuadrado
es menos 9 entonces a es igual a menos 9
que hay de b b es el coeficiente de x en
este caso es menos 9 también noten que
aquí llevo un más por lo tanto aquí me
tiene que ser igual a menos 9
y sé que es el término independiente por
lo tanto se en este caso es igual a 6
entonces simplemente voy a sustituir
estos valores en la fórmula cuadrática y
voy a obtener que x va a ser igual a
menos b que sería menos -9 menos -9 más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b al cuadrado
que es menos 9 al cuadrado que es 81
menos 4 veces los 4 veces a que sería
menos 9 por c que sería 6
todo eso dentro de la raíz dividido
entre dos veces a que sería 2 x menos 9
ok cuánto es esto menos por menos me da
más así que esto es 9 + menos la raíz
cuadrada de 81 4 por 9 es 36 y menos por
menos es más así que tengo 36 por 6 36
por 5 y 180 más 36 sería 216 así que 81
más 216
116 y todo eso lo voy a dividir entre
menos 18
así que esto es 9 + menos la raíz
cuadrada de 81 216 sería 297 me parecen
297 10 297 entre menos 18
ahora bien creo que aquí puedo
factorizar un 9 veamos 2 7 9 y 9 18 que
es divisible entre 9 así que 297 es
divisible entre 9
y cuántas veces van nueve en 297
pues veamos 9 va en 29 para tres veces
me sobran 2
el 7 927 otras tres veces y me sobran 0
así que esto es lo mismo que no voy a
cambiar de color para romper la
monotonía 9 + menos la raíz cuadrada de
9 por 33 la raíz cuadrada de 9 es 3
así que esto es lo mismo que tres veces
la raíz cuadrada de 33 entre menos 18
de modo que
si ahora
y ahora simplemente / todo entre 3
obtengo 9 entre 3 s 3 más menos ese 13
cancela más menos la raíz cuadrada de 33
entre menos 18 entre 3 es menos 6
entonces aquí están mis dos soluciones
tengo dos soluciones a partir de esto
una para el signo más y una para el
signo menos que incidentalmente tengo un
signo más y un signo menos precisamente
porque la raíz cuadrada puede ser
positiva o negativa pero bueno entonces
mis dos soluciones son x1 va a ser igual
a 3 + la raíz cuadrada de 33
en 36
y x2 va a ser igual a 3 perdón menos 63
menos la raíz cuadrada de 33
entre -6 estas son las dos soluciones a
esta ecuación son las dos raíces de este
polinomio las dos intersecciones con el
eje x hagamos otro ejemplo bien
consideremos ahora
- 8 x al cuadrado más 5 x más 9 igual a
quiero resolver esto y supongo que ya se
aprendieron la fórmula cuadrática pero
si no lo hicieron
háganlo aquí la voy a poner por el
momento ok
bien entonces que me dice la fórmula
cuadrática pues me dice que las
soluciones son estas de aquí y en este
caso tengo que a vale cuanto a vale
menos 8 y b vale cuanto vea ahora vale 5
hice vale 9 algo que debo advertirles es
que estos polinomios podrían estar
desordenados podría por ejemplo aparecer
5 x menos 8 x al cuadrado más 9 siempre
es el coeficiente de x al cuadrado de x
ese es el término independiente ajena
mente al orden en el que aparezca
escrito el polinomio pero bueno
sustituyó estos valores en la fórmula
cuadrática y obtengo menos b que sería
menos 5 + menos la raíz cuadrada de
vamos a ponerlo aquí x es igual a menos
5 más menos la raíz cuadrada de b al
cuadrado que sería 25 menos 4 a c menos
4 x
a que es menos 8 por sé que es 9
todo es en raíz dividido entre dos veces
a que sería 2 x menos 8 que es menos 16
entonces x es igual a cuánto vamos a
cambiar de color x va a ser igual a
menos 5 + menos la raíz cuadrada de 25 -
bueno vamos a ver qué signos al menos 4
x menos 8 es 32 positivo 32 positivo por
9 32 por 9 sería 320 menos 32 que es 288
si mal no estoy
288 25 288 todo eso dividido entre menos
y esto cuánto nos da pues esto es menos
5 más menos la raíz cuadrada de 25 288
que sería 313
- 5 - la raíz cuadrada de 313 todo eso
dividido entre menos 16
ahora bien 313 no tiene ningún factor
cuadrado no tiene ningún factor que sea
un número al cuadrado de hecho creo que
313 es un número primo no estoy seguro
pero bueno lo que significa es que no
puedo simplificar más este radical y que
entonces mis soluciones van a ser x1
igual a menos 5 y me tomo el más menos 5
+ 313
todo entre menos 16 y x2 de nuevo menos
5 ahora me voy a tomar el menos menos
raíz cuadrada de 313 dividido entre
menos 16 y ya no puedo simplificar más
estas dos raíces estas son las
soluciones a esta ecuación de aquí
son las raíces de este polinomio o son
las soluciones a esta ecuación
y bueno como último comentario recuerden
tengo dos soluciones en general siempre
que este número no sea cero voy a tener
una solución con él más y una solución
con el menos en vídeos futuros les
enseñaré incluso a ver qué pasa cuando
lo que está dentro del radical tiene
signo negativo eso son interesantes pero
bueno espero esto les haya ayudado y que
puedan resolver ejercicios de este
estilo ustedes solos